hello and welcome to awesome comics your
one-stop shop for everything comic
entertainment I am your host Walter for
Daisy Ike and today we were talking
about the brand new movie Doctor Strange
starring Benedict Cumberbatch it's the
latest offering from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and before we get
into it I want to remind you guys to
like our Facebook page that is
facebook.com slash awesome comics show
and we have new videos that go up on
there every single Thursday exclusive to
that Facebook page so go ahead and give
us a like well yeah okay let's get into
the intros here let's go to this guy
first
he is mr. Brian Porter and we have Ayane
Wade what's up Ayane not much we get to
benedict's in this movie to magnetic one
and and miss Heather Roose how's it
going hey it's going great
ready to talk about Doctor Strange yes I
am I'm also ready to talk about Bennet
and our special guest today you saw him
a couple weeks ago on our favorite anime
episode it's mr. Rob Walker that's good
thank you I love the Cape I really do so
here's a spoiler warning for you guys
we're gonna go into spoilers about this
I've even seen the movie yet go see it
or if you don't have you don't care
about spoilers just keep watching I
honestly I don't explore I can't ruin
this movie like there's nothing really
in it that is gonna ruin your enjoyment
of it I think just my opinon but so
what's getting a positive what did we
like about this movie the most Rob what
did you like about Doctor Strange the
Cumberbatch honestly honestly the
visuals I at least since gravity which I
thought was a very visually heavy movie
probably some of the best visuals I've
seen inception the matrix I you know and
I saw the trailers I thought oh well
this will look cool but I thought you
know they probably just saved all of
this just for like five minutes and this
up in the trailer and I really the first
few minutes in the movie I was like holy
crap and pretty much the whole way to
the end I'm like yeah this probably some
of the most spectacular effects I've
seen since inception gravity The Matrix
like I think it ranks up they would like
you know 2001 Star Wars and the weird
thing is I didn't think like going into
this because I was really looking
forward to this movie but I didn't think
like oh this will be remembered as one
of the great special effects films of
all times movie I'm like I came out it
was like wow that was mind-blowing
so I that's it's my favorite part of the
visuals okay poor George affair except
mine was actually visuals - I was
floored with how good this movie was
like they had to have had like half the
budget into the VFX because yeah look so
good it was crisp it was clean like
there was no like weird like blur
between like the buildings forming all
crazy mounted styles and all that stuff
like it was so crisp and clean and it
looked awesome so good in that
straight-up acid trip that Benedict
Cumberbatch with her Doctor Strange went
on was fantastic there was so much
going the fingers coming out of the
finger much just ridiculousness going on
I was like man this is a movie that
makes me wish I did take drugs cuz I
would come to bed high off of my ass
this movie was amazing and it was so
trippy and they've told us like it was
gonna be not like anything we've seen
before and it just looked so good
everything about the movie was just they
put a lot of time and effort in these
VFX and it was awesome and I'm gonna be
genuinely curious to see how these
effects hold up over time yeah like in
10 years I recently look back at this
movie and be like you know what this
still looks awesome it looks pretty good
I hope so I mean with what they
presented us I think it will but I'm
genuinely curious like I was just about
to say that you see yeah it was like
the Essure meets Dalia with the cars
melting over the side and they're all
trying to like how like how did they did
that with the green-screen so like had
to be hard as hell interested in seeing
the special effects behind them behind
absolutely um when they have like
they're like glass shards or whatever I
don't know where the glass world shard
things that they're holding like do they
just like have green sticks and stuff or
even the makeup and what's his but nads
face oh I can't his eye makeup I was
like debating whether or not that was
like green-screen makeup cuz there was
some animation oh yeah at first I
thought someone just came in and it was
like purple gold foil let's do it real
good so when he's crying it's like yeah
that my likes pretty much just like
talking normally in his eyes like
willing up and just tears points the
whole movie is like I love the movie
about the visuals of the Starks like at
the same time I'm just like it's kind of
like I think Cisco once said about the
first Mission Possible movie about how
Tom Cruise is like you never quite know
what he's doing but you really feel it
I feel something I'm not sure what but I
feel something and most movies a lot of
them I don't really feel anything and
they're what anything else that you
really liked about it um one of the
things that I liked is the progression
of doctor Strange's jury like we've
really got to see him progress as not
just like a superhero because it's
pretty easy to just like put on the Cape
and be like ah but like we got to see
him really change and grow as a human
being which I really appreciated a lot
of the character growths and I was
really invested in his journey which is
always good for an origin story few
times like the IMAX audience when he
unleashes on her and is like the whole
audience is yeah oh
collective gasp and then like somebody
in the very back of the audience shouted
oh no you
yeah yeah I like that see where she's
just like you know what we're done here
like it wasn't like I see where like I'm
destroyed and all but she's like screw
you I'm uh yeah I was like it was a
great scene I was like that's like
something that almost no I don't think
sorry what I mean it is pretty funny to
see Benedict Cumberbatch just be playing
the same I was like definitely
channeling some Sherlock in there just
doesn't quite know how to interact with
other humans yeah but I think his uh
he's like a apology to Christine and all
that stuff was like so genuine and it
just it worked really well there was
nothing forced about it you know it
wasn't like too early in the story or
anything yeah it works so well and her
reaction to it felt super genuine to it
was like it was really well acted film
it wasn't like a great film and in terms
of like character development and then
narrative or whatever like it wasn't
like amazing but like it just works so
well with all the characters yes very
solid he has an intensity yeah because
she was this another thing where I was
like I don't know how to feel because
she was kind of creepy but then she's
like so warm and like right and the
action sequences to I'd be interested to
see because as a general rule of thumb a
lot of times if you don't see the actors
faces yeah so I'd be interested to see
how much of it she did because there was
a lot of really really cool fighting yes
I getting with the fan and stuff like
those Celtic gals they're hardcore all
we know of Iron Sheik al she's Celtic
and she's lived for like a million years
somehow captured the essence of that
like ancient knowledge I believe that
there's that wisdom there you know
I mean it's like I know exactly what
you're thinking right now yeah just
follow me like tell the swinish it's not
a physical level I gotta say it the face
yes there were scenes where she's like
scares through the camera and I'm like
looking at her like look at my soul
directly even the psycho like her
introduction was kind of cool too I was
like when he walked in at the same time
I was kind of like I like when it's Brad
Jones laughs like it's funny because the
vision was gonna be an Asian yeah I feel
like they were trying to like disarm us
a bit with all the the quote/unquote
controversy and I say I don't know if I
would have just preferred that they just
kind of just went in with a bad joke
because then it just reminded me like oh
my god like within the first few minutes
of the film I was like these costumes
are so well constructed I agree there's
so like even just that Cape cloak cloak
II it was the real heroes around the
sewer it was pulling him back he's like
Oh seen up from when he goes into the
New York branch all the way up until
they come back to the hospital and stuff
that whole action scene it's just like a
really long great intense action scene
man it was good you really blended the
humor with the action very well as well
they broke it up a little there was so
a lot - there's some sort of thing it
really tends and they really think about
the audience and give it okay you can
laugh here here's where you can like
just let out kind of your pent up
whatever you've got going on yeah and
yeah the fact they made a costume
character just in general the the design
of everything was phenomenal yeah so
good I really liked you gotta make sure
it catches the light though little
glimmer
stuff that I liked about it I mean I
think the thing I like most about it was
that how it it was like a sort of a
basic jerk redeemed kind of story but it
was presented in a way that felt so
fresh and unique from the other Marvel
movies like this really feels different
for me from the other ones I mean maybe
the structure a little bit is is similar
here and there but the elements that
they deal with the magic stuff we
haven't seen quite yet me a little bit
Thor but really dove into that with all
the ash projection and the the sling
rings yeah I like that we get to see
them learn all this stuff we get to see
them go through all the sort of the
training here and there I'm just
believing am on Everest oh not again
yeah I thought that was great so but it
felt different and not meaning it
mentions the Avengers like once like the
Avengers protect the world from physical
threats while we protect it from
spiritual threats or yeah I thought that
was a nice thing to throw in but they
really didn't cross it over too much
like this felt very self-contained I
like that about it I did see the
Avengers tower in the beginning yeah I
like the Avengers I the second they
started going that route of just like
well but they're the physical threat
we're the mystical side I'm just sold
I want this serious nothing against the
Avengers but I'm just like I got way
more wrapped up into this one right and
it just it's feels so fresh to me right
I think some of it is I don't know how
to quite explain it but the characters
and this one really felt real like you
had taken real characters and put them
in these outlandish situations I mean
it's insane and it's goofy but you know
he felt real the nurse felt real every
great test it's one of the relationships
I've seen yeah like it really was and
the the movie wasn't really like about
them and to me it's kind of a sides her
but I think that was yeah I was like I
really believe this relationship they
have from the ups and the downs and the
that was rare and refreshing because so
many times that's the weakness in a
comic yeah yeah because we're kind of
being thrown into this like even when
he's like yeah I have to go back to this
like time portal thing she's like okay
don't tell me he's like okay well here's
the broom closet okay small details too
with the characters like when he's like
which is with his watch
oh it's just an expensive watch but then
he takes it off he looks and it's like
bah bah bah whatever it said yeah all
lovey-dovey were Christian it's like wow
all right put some at the end
yeah yeah and the glasses they gave me
we're actually like dirty and then like
he's like puts the watch back I'm like
something happened my goodness I hate I
hate 3d glasses so much they're so
annoying specifically as a glasses where
it's one of a really frustrating
experience like this double yeah this
was one of those that you really should
go see it in IMAX receive it and three
if you can I say go see it because I saw
it and it's it's really it's it's kind
of built for that you know a lot of
depth yeah I just can't take 3d minutes
I just carry it makes me sick so I have
it really strange my eyes like my eyes
go in out of focus and I just I just
can't do it for like a full movie like
I'm with you but if and my problem with
3d is it is so overused because the
gimmick like and when they just do
retroactive we you know just like oh
yeah we're releasing in 3d as well I'm
like screw that so most of them I don't
think you need to see in 3d at all but
this is one of the rare ones there's a
rare set of films I could probably count
on like my one hand and I'm like no
those needed to be seen in 3d and I'm
glad I saw them in Franky
you know this is definitely so we've
talked about our positive and we just
collected our checks from Disney so
thanks where is my check it was like oh
you just being paid off by Disney I'm
okay with that
where is it I can be bought anyway we've
talked about the positives is there
anything you guys didn't like about this
or stuck out to you as not great the
only thing that wasn't like I see I feel
like no matter what we do is kind of
just nitpicking at this point yeah but I
feel like the villain was super generic
like very we've seen it already both OH
you know like ooh of course the Dark
Dimension is like this old Dark Lord who
controls everything and then the other
villain was like the Fallen pupil who
makes the master realize she can't make
the same mistake again it was just kind
of okay the henchman didn't even have
like cuz you're preaching to the choir
here at least with me about like
Marvel's Achilles heel is always it's a
villain so yeah yeah who remembers half
of them there's Loki
I'd like to Roman oh people I really I
liked Ronan - but that was kind of he
was so over the time yeah but one of the
rare that it didn't bother me just cuz
his personal jurors strangers personal
journey was so interesting that unlike
other Marvel movies where bothers me
where I'm just like the villain said in
the supreme moment about this one I'm
just like you know I'm not sure I would
have needed it because the more you
would have focused on the villain the
less of Doctor Strange I see and I was
more interested in him and his journey
that sentence weird face right we have
to see Dormammu at the end that was yeah
that was a Futurama like ending yeah I
was kind of hoping he'd be more fiery
than mmm oh yeah bees in the comments a
lot of at least what I've read he was
yeah very flamin has got a nose light I
see I feel like he could have been
Bannos his dad like something out of his
pores yeah well it did look awesome and
visually look yeah that the Dark
Dimension or whatever and he was funny I
love the end scene with time loo I've
come too far I've come to bargain I like
that a lot
yeah I can do this all day
we'll just keep earth frozen in time
forever as long as they're not gonna die
yes it's fine yeah we're doing great
yeah as far as negatives I don't I don't
really have too many but yeah the
villain okay yeah a little weak but uh
there was one scene it there was only
one scene with the visuals that I didn't
quite like or which thought was a little
weird is that it was when they were both
the actual ancient one and then strange
and they're a special protecting and
they were watching the lightning over
her face I know that they were astral
projection so like they were gonna look
weird anyway but for some reason it
looks like they took her mouth off and
then put another one on
but it was her mouth if they did some
weird pry and her face looked weird
yeah action effect it looked like they I
mean they obviously like turn down the
opacity and then it looked like they
added like some CG elements or something
on it there it was yeah but I was like
okay it's actual projection so it's
really not that big of a deal and it was
just something I noticed I didn't I
didn't know I didn't even take me out I
just kind of noticed those like it's
weird but I was fine with it
but other than that like it was it's
fine like I didn't have anything that I
really didn't like although the fact
that uh Scott Adkins was one of the he
was the one that got his ass beat by the
cloak he was the the henchman I like
Scott Adkins a lot and I was like damn
he was super underutilized in this film
guys are freaking martial arts badass
and he got his ass kicked by a close
fight
self in that scene won't be real until
they put that cloak on he was just going
like this a lot I talked about this in
the Batman 66 for you I love what people
have to fight and they're like you got
it you got it director we're gonna have
to wrap this up up really quickly where
does this fit in to the other MCU movies
is this near the top for you guys middle
what do you think Rob really quickly you
know I mean the story with itself was
nothing to scream home about and he want
to talk about the only one negative I
had was Benedict Cumberbatch is amazing
disappearing reappearing it only
happened like once or twice it was
really distracting for me but the
visuals are so strong I think the
characters is so much fun I I would rank
it absolutely near the top okay okay
easily I got you
well yeah I would say near the top too
but I did want to mention because I know
people would be like why didn't you
mention this Wong's character was really
awesome all she would tell you for I
might not be saying that right I caught
his character was great it was quite a
depth I guess yeah I loved it
mid-credits scene yet that I thought
that was really good really flushed him
out and then I don't know that was the
end and then the the mid-credits scene
with Thor did I miss something after
Thor - is that or am I supposed to know
what the heck I don't know know it
sounds like they like Thor already found
out that Loki was sitting on the throne
or whatever okay because I just sank
them like I think we miss one of the
movies so very because we got to get
going here so where would you rank this
one top five probably have five I can um
I don't think it's quite in my top five
but definitely top 10 so there it's
still no guardians the galaxy for me
yeah
yeah but like it's up there visually
speaking it's it's one of the man yeah
if we're just talking visuals that'd be
my number launcher there was no other
one that same realm of way more
connected to that than anything on the
event yeah definitely yeah I'm about the
same it might be top five for me I mean
I really really liked it's like the
first Iron Man guardians of the galaxy
this Avengers are all up there so I'm
kept America Winter Soldier soldier and
Civil War up there for me too so Mar
we'll just keep put on consistent
quality products and as long as things
are different enough I don't think the
fatigue will set in and like the
superhero fatigue people are talking
about I don't think that will set in for
a long time as long as I keep making
things just different enough like they
are at Marvel so good on them really
quickly
social media Rob you're on Facebook
right I have a facebook find him on
Facebook Porter facebook.com slash
awesome Porter you can find me at
awesome underscore Walter I think and
you can find me on Twitter at Heather
ruse or Instagram at a truce okay so
until next week we're gonna have a
couple special guests we're gonna do
something a little bit different next
week so come back but that's gonna be
quite them and the in-floor shadow weed
until next week these folks as usual are
the best
I'm all Trapani's yak and until next
week we'll see you on the next page
you